halo is not only one of the most iconic
game series of all time but it's the
franchise most associated with xbox in
2021 both xbox and the master chief
turned 20 years old and it's hard to
imagine what the first person shooter
landscape would look like today if it
weren't for a little game called
monkey nuts
this is the history of halo
in the 90s bungie developer jason jones
was working on a little something in the
background inspired by the success of
starcraft and wanting to take bungie's
own game myth and give it a sci-fi spin
he began tinkering away on a real-time
strategy game that was codenamed monkey
nuts not wanting to tell his mum the
name of the game he was working on jones
changed it to blam
eventually more people were added to the
team and the game switched to third
person when they realized it was way
more fun to have control when driving by
early 1999 blam was ready to make its
debut
bungie showed the game behind closed
doors at e3 and generated buzz by making
those who saw it sign strict ndas they
leveraged some connections at apple and
showed the game to steve jobs impressed
he gave it stage time at mac world that
summer this is one of the coolest i've
ever seen this game is going to ship
early next year from bungie and we're
going to see for the first time halo
but despite the momentum it still didn't
have a name until a couple of days
before the show for a while it was
called covenant until paul russell one
of the game's artists called that name
stupid and came up with a bunch of
alternatives one of those was halo which
like a well-timed plasma grenade stuck
the combat evolved tagline was added
later to make it a little more military
from the first bars of what would become
its iconic theme tune to the beautiful
open playground it promised halo
impressed now all bungie had to do was
make it
in 1998 bungie accidentally shipped myth
2 with one hell of a bug if you
uninstalled the game it would wipe your
hard drive bungie spent around 800
thousand dollars recalling copies of
myth 2 which left them in bad financial
shape they secured some cash flow from
take 2 but needed more very quickly
bungie found itself going broke then
executive vice president peter tampter
who got them the meeting with apple
reached out to microsoft to talk about
an acquisition microsoft who were
looking to fill the launch lineup for
the original xbox took a chance buying
both the studio and the rights to halo
thus the relationship between bungie and
xbox began if you're wondering whether
steve jobs and apple were pissed the
answer is yes but they agreed to port
the game to mack and steve seemed
alright with that
with steady cash flow and a launch
window in mind development on halo could
begin in earnest it became first person
to make players feel more connected to
the game and the character of the master
chief and the team began piecing
together the campaign while a lot of
work was done to ensure that the game
felt good when played on a controller
some other elements didn't have that
luxury ideas were cut story duct tape
was used to ensure that the campaign was
even finished and the game's promised
open world never came to fruition even
halo's beloved multiplayer was allegedly
on the chopping block for a while bungie
just couldn't figure out how to make it
fun until the very end of the project
when it was completely rebuilt a blow
came to morale when the game was shown
off at e3 2001 to a mixed reception due
to its bad frame rate despite that
bungie persisted but the team was
struggling months of crunch was leaving
its mark and people were burning out
composer marty o'donnell was only given
three days to score and add sound
effects to all of the game's cutscenes
but they got it done and bungie managed
to pull off something special
[Music]
halo launched on november 15 2001 to
universal critical acclaim we gave it a
9.7 out of 10 praising its controls
stunning environments and even calling
it one of the few first-person shooters
that manages to transcend its genre
sales-wise it didn't light the charts on
fire immediately instead it was more of
a slow burn but it went down in history
as one of the best launch games of all
time and it was the beginning of an
iconic franchise halo combat evolved
anniversary a remastered remake of the
game was released in 2011 and it was
developed by 343 industries which became
custodians of the franchise after bungie
gained its independence from microsoft
in 2007 and saber interactive the game
allowed players to switch between the
old visuals and the new at will not long
after the release of halo the team at
bungie started work on the sequel
after all there had been so many ideas
cut from the original game they had
plenty of material to work with for a
new entry
however it wasn't exactly plain sailing
feeling the pressure to release a
follow-up to a hit game coupled with the
ambition to make it bigger and better
led to conflicts between the key
creatives working on the team
particularly when it came to its single
player part way through development halo
2 project lead jason jones left the team
to work on phoenix a successor to myth
that was being made by a small team
within bungie at e3 2003 halo 2 took to
the main stage with an impressive demo
that blew crowds away in-game demo
of halo 2.
unfortunately it was all fake it's not
uncommon for developers to show work in
progress or target footage that they
hope will represent the final product
but the e3 2003 showcase was a line in
the sand moment for bungie the graphics
engine in the demo wouldn't work on an
xbox after the show they scrapped the
entire graphics engine and started again
phoenix was cancelled and the entire
team was put on halo 2. the sequel was
delayed by a year and what followed was
a period of extended crunch for the team
the campaign had been in the works for a
year and a half but the dev team had to
completely redesign it bungie never
planned on the series becoming a trilogy
and wanted to finish it with a climactic
ending that would see master chief and
halo 2's other playable protagonist the
arbiter a covenant character who would
show the war from the other side joining
forces on earth
to save time halo 2's final act was cut
with the game ending on a cliffhanger
which proved to be divisive master chief
you mind telling me what you're doing on
that ship
sir
finishing this fight
multiplayer meanwhile was almost the
opposite story while the single player
was undergoing a tumultuous overhaul the
multiplayer had been playable for two
years in 2002 xbox launched xbox live
and realizing that outside of lan
parties that could bring up to 16
players together few would get to
experience proper halo multiplayer
bungie leaned heavily into online
connectivity this helped halo carve its
legacy as an iconic multiplayer
experience with some fans continuing to
play it for weeks after the servers were
turned off in 2010 to keep them alive
you can't close the club if people
refuse to leave halo 2's release window
was critical it was the final christmas
before the launch of the xbox 360 and
they needed to hit it bungie crunched
and managed to hit its deadline halo 2
launched november 9th 2004. the game hit
records for the number of pre-orders and
it was supported by an arg called i love
bees that drummed up interest once again
it launched a critical acclaim and sold
over 2 million copies in 24 hours
overtaking the second pirates of the
caribbean movie as the highest grossing
entertainment release of the time
despite its success bungie wasn't
completely happy with halo 2. team
members called its multiplayer a pale
shadow of what it could and should have
been and called its ending underwhelming
taking halo 3 as an opportunity to make
right for halo 2 the team went into halo
3 looking to close master chief's story
we're not leaving him here
yeah
you're not
oh
crazy fool
why do you always jump
one of these days you're going to land
on something as stubborn as you are
and i don't do bits and pieces
jason jones took a sabbatical from
bungie but his presence was still felt
the team had a cardboard cut out of him
in the studio no one was explicitly in
control of the project and the project
had a clumsy start with misaligned
visions for what the game should be
another lead joe statton left the studio
on a sabbatical after an argument he
went to work on other halo projects
including a cancelled halo mmo then
later halo wars he also worked with lord
of the rings director peter jackson who
was not only in the process of founding
his own game studio wingnut games but
was in pre-production on a halo movie in
new zealand with guillermo del toro neil
blomkamp and a script that was being
worked on by alex garland and dan vice
halo chronicles the game made by bungie
and jackson would have you play as a
marine who had alien tech attached to
their arm ultimately the game and the
movie fell through but some ideas were
eventually used in odst
despite some crunch halo 3 was a more
enjoyable development experience than
two for the team they didn't have to
make huge cuts and even had time to add
things like forge mode which allows
players to make their own maps
it was marketed heavily by microsoft
with the famous believe campaign
as well as a number of tie-ins with
brands like pepsi new mountain dew game
fuel
cranked up for halo 3.
chug it and have no mercy unfortunately
the game leaked online months before it
was due to be released and bungie
retaliated by banning the xbox live
accounts of those playing it until the
year
9999
when the game did finally release on
september 27th it was a smash hit both
critically and commercially halo 3 is
here but throughout the development of
the game tensions had risen between
microsoft and bungie bungie hit their
profit cap for halo 2 on the game's
launch day and so were eager to
renegotiate to get more money despite
the success of halo the two split in
2007. bungie became an independent
entity but microsoft owned the rights to
halo a minority stake in the studio and
the promise of some more games for
summer bungie who wanted to work on
something new this was an issue
about time i was down on my last clip
halo wars took the franchise back to its
rts roots made by ensemble studios
developer of age of empires it was an
rts built with the 360 controller in
mind but it wasn't originally intended
to be a halo game microsoft suggested
the franchise to ensemble which didn't
go down well with bungie who didn't
appreciate their ip being used by
another studio bungie developers
allegedly saw the move as quote the
whoring out of our franchise halo wars
took place around 20 years before the
events of halo combat evolved an
ensemble faithfully recreated all of
bungie's assets themselves to nail the
look and tone of the world the game
released to a positive reception with
numerous outlets praising how the game
controlled on console our review
criticized it for its shallow rts
elements and lamented that you couldn't
play as any covenant or flood characters
a covenant campaign had actually been
cut due to time manpower and money sadly
ensemble closed down shortly after the
game shipped
[Applause]
halo 3 odst was made in 14 months with
the peter jackson game falling through
there was a team of experienced
developers ready to go and a lot of
ideas kicking around bungie decided it
was possible to make a game in that time
while the rest of the team was working
on halo reach
after all they had their engine universe
and lore ready to work with they wanted
the game to be more character driven and
so picked a specific place within the
world new mombasa and told a more human
story driven by odsts orbital drop shock
troopers who were still handy with a gun
but not as powerful as the chief this
necessitated changes like silenced
pistols being added to the game and the
new health system made players feel more
vulnerable the vibe was also remarkably
different instead of open lush greens
odst mostly took place within the
confines of a city and the whole game
had a film noir vibe
the game was originally called halo 3
recon but after the ghost recon team
caught wind of that the name was changed
it was very different for halo and
bungie wanted to release it at a 30
price tag unfortunately microsoft
disagreed seeing it as a chance to have
a new halo for christmas it charged 60
for it odst had multiplayer and even a
new wave based mode called firefight but
it was divisive upon release some
praised the bold new direction whereas
others thought it was a glorified
expansion but for the team at bungie who
made it despite the reception it was
just nice to work on something a little
different i've seen your file even the
parts the oni census didn't want me to
i'm glad to have your skill set
but we're a team
that lone wolf stuff stays behind clear
got it sir
welcome to reach
while a number of the team was working
on odst another team within bungie was
working on halo reach at one point it
was going to be a sequel to halo 3 but
that was rejected in favor of trying
something new halo fans would already
know that the colony of reach was doomed
so the challenge for the team lay in
writing a story and characters
particularly the team of noble 6 that
players would connect with despite
knowing their doomed fate halo reach was
released to extraordinary high praise
from players and critics alike becoming
the third best-selling game of 2010.
many claimed that it took the best bits
of previous halo games and elevated them
while adding new gameplay mechanics like
jet packs and customization to make it
feel fresh it would be the last halo
game from bungie with a number of the
team having already transitioned to
working on the studio's next big project
destiny
reach would be bungie's swan song for
the franchise and what a way for the
team to go out
children's minds are more easily
accepting of indoctrination
their bodies more adaptable to
augmentation the result
was the ultimate soldier
and because of our success
when the covenant invaded
we were ready when bungie split from
microsoft plans were immediately put in
motion to build a new studio to take
responsibility for halo 343 industries
named for the character 343 guilty spark
was set up in seattle but only one
member of the bungie halo team decided
to go and join it content manager frank
o'connor who'd been with the team since
halo 2. there was slight animosity
between the two studios with composer
marty o'donnell seeing 343 as
competitors even going as far as to say
we were trying to make the halo killer
and they were trying to make halo while
the bungee games hadn't been set up as a
trilogy and they'd attempted to sunset
the characters of chief and cortana 343
was deliberately setting up its halo
story with arcs that spanned across
numerous games taking chief and cortana
on new adventures with new looks 343
decided to also explore the forerunners
an ancient race mostly untouched by halo
lore as well as introduce their own new
race to the universe the prometheans
production on halo 4 wasn't simple not
only was the team being built from
scratch and growing rapidly but the
direction of the game also changed
pretty dramatically throughout
development its original creative
director ryan payton who previously
worked at konami on metal gear solid 4
had a very different vision for what
halo 4 would be wanting to take risks
with the franchise such as missions with
no shooting after two years payton was
demoted to narrative director and josh
holmes took over basically rebooting the
entire project halo 4 felt like a sequel
to halo 3 and was a game that venerated
its source material while gently trying
to change things too the critical
reception was positive with praise being
lorded on the more human connection
between chief and cortana while some die
hard fans were yet to be convinced by
343 and even some bungie folks thinking
halo 4 played it a little too safe it
was the biggest halo launch yet think of
my axe
as you will
but do not doubt the reality
the reclamation
has already begun
[Music]
and we are hopeless to stop it
halo spartan assault is a top-down twin
stick shooter that released in 2013 for
mobile as well as eventually consoles
and pc it came to xbox one shortly after
the console's release making it the big
halo game for that window it was the
first mobile halo game and by playing
you could unlock xp for halo 4. it got
middling reviews with reviews praising
its bite-sized missions by criticizing
its in-app purchases but it did get a
sequel called spartan strike in 2015
with halo 4 launching on the 360 and a
while to wait until halo 5 on xbox one
343 industries began thinking about
plugging the gap by remastering halo 2
in the same vein as halo combat evolved
anniversary 343 then decided to
re-release the halo games in one
collection while each game received a
graphical bump halo 2 received the most
work getting the complete remaster
treatment with new cutscenes redone
audio work remade multiplayer maps as
well as new animations to tie into the
upcoming halo 5. at launch the
collection included halo combat evolved
anniversary and 2 anniversary halo 3 and
4 with all their multiplayers
unfortunately the launch was plagued by
matchmaking errors which 343 dutifully
worked to fix over the years more halo
games have been added as well as new
achievements it was also updated for
xbox series x and s allowing players to
hit up to
frames per second the collection also
launched on pc with fans so excited at
the reveal that they inundated 343's
offices with free pizza as a sign of
gratitude they sent so many that 343 had
to politely ask them to stop
[ __ ] online and ready spartanvale online
weapons free
contact
halo 5 was announced at e3 2013 with a
brief teaser 343 began to take more
risks like introducing more main
characters a spartan squad with their
own abilities who would accompany you
and take orders from you throughout the
game a lot of halo 5's marketing focused
on a new character lock who was chasing
down chief across the galaxy after
cortana's death at the end of halo 4.
the game was supported by a genuinely
pretty cool accompanying audio play
starring keegan michael key who was
determined to expose a cover-up about
the master chief when you're a war
journalist you see a lot of horrible
stuff
all the stories i've done i've seen the
absolute worst of humanity
but i've also gotten to see the best
halo 4's multiplayer player count
dropped off
quickly so 343 wanted to get ambitious
with five the engine changed to allow
the game to run its bigger levels at 60
frames per second and with multiplayer
they added a 24 person mode plus ai
called warzone no not to be confused
with that one they also made halo feel a
little more modern with additions like
being able to aim down the sights of
every weapon which doesn't sound huge
but it really was halo 5 was the first
halo game other than halo wars to ship
without an m rating earning a t for teen
instead it was also the first game to
not ship with split screen co-op sales
wise it was huge but the reception was
kind of all over the place some people
really enjoyed the changes and the bold
new direction for the story others found
it meandering and that it doubled down
on the bad parts of halo 4. it's not a
bad game but it never hit the highs of
previous halos and for that reason
it's kind of just not talked about
do look after everyone for me would you
goodbye captain
serena out
[Music]
wanting to give an rts halo another shot
343 teamed up with total war developer
creative assembly for halo wars 2. with
the game coming to both pc and console
the development team was made up of
talent who experienced making games for
both as it included folks who had worked
on total war and alien isolation
while the game looked really nice in
particular its cutscenes thanks to
animation studio blur it suffered the
same issues as the original its rts
elements were too shallow it also faced
criticism for its unsatisfactory ending
and the inclusion of microtransactions
yep this is death
[Music]
[Applause]
which brings us to halo infinite get
ready originally it was supposed to
launch with the xbox series x and s in
november 2020 but it was delayed due to
the pandemic but also it didn't leave
the best first impression when gameplay
was shown at the xbox games showcase in
summer 2020 people weren't impressed by
its graphics one particular brute later
named craig inspired a whole lot of
memes
but there were a lot of people
interested to see the changes that 343
was making including moving from the
usually linear campaign into a semi-open
world and adding more abilities like a
grappling hook to quickly traverse
around the world and close distance to
enemies these abilities would also be
making their way into the multiplayer
interest in its single player set to
focus on chief hunting for the missing
cortana rose when it was revealed that
joseph staton former lead writer at
bungie was joining 343 to work on the
game on november 15th the 20th
anniversary of the original xbox and
halo 343 announced that the multiplayer
beta was available to play for free
right then and there on xbox and steam
and damn that game felt good it
skyrocketed up the steam charts racking
up a peak of 200 000 concurrent players
with cries of halo is back on social
media and while single player was on
track to hit its release date of
december 8th campaign co-op and forge
mode were both delayed into 2022 with
the team only wanting to ship them when
they were ready
if you want to watch the full timeline
of all the lore of halo which i didn't
really get into in this video make sure
to check out jessie's extensive video
here huge shout out to vice for their
amazing article the untold story of halo
which is full of tidbits about the
creation of these games i really
recommend you read it if you like halo
and if you made it this far i assume you
do i'll link it below for more halo make
sure to like and subscribe and i'll
catch you next time
[Music]